Quoi ?
What the fuck ?
Nooon !
C'est typique, ça.
Toi aussi, tu l'entends ?
Alors, bon trimestre, mais chante Hakuna Matata
en classe...
C'est pas vrai, je deviens folle !
Bonjour !
Comme vous pouvez le constater, notre chère
prof manque d'inspiration en ce moment, c'est
pourquoi il n'y aura pas de nouvel épisode
avant les fêtes.
J'en suis la première désolée, mais je
vous promet de la harceler avec la musique
du générique jusqu'à ce qu'elle se mette
au travail.
Cette feignasse.
En attendant je vous souhaite de bonnes fêtes
de fin d'année, et pour vous faire patienter
jusqu'à l'épisode de janvier j'ai décidé
de révéler tous les moments un peu nuls
de nos tournages, juste après ce message.
Portez vous bien, passez de bonnes fêtes,
et comme on dit chez moi: Victoriae mundis
et mundis lacrima.
Et d'autres enfin n'avaient rien à voir avec
la choucroute, mais décidaient de réaliser
une prédiction pour un fr...pr... merde.
Jean de Vésale, au service de Charles le
Téméraire, réalise une préd... (aboiement)
putain.
Ambulance.
Puisqu'on considère que les français se
sont fait écraser parce qu'ils étaient moins
patriotes que les allemands.
Prussiens, prussiens.
Ils pouvaient être équipés de haches, mais
elles étaient plutôt des armes de jet...
-Ça va ?
-Oui, ça va.
There's a liiiight...
Over at my "bureau".
L'étude de Clovis, notamment son baptême,
permet par exemple de montrer l'unicité chr...
Chrétienne, chrétienne.
C'est trop facile, ils sont tellement mauvais,
ça serait...
(coups de marteau)
Putain...
On préfère également se concentrer sur
une histoire globale...Non, merde, c'est l'inverse
!
Merde, je sais pas si je filme.
Oh, je filme !
Say what you're gonna do.
What you're gonna do, when they come for you.
Ils pouvaient être équipés de haches, mais
elles étaient plutôt des armes de jet...
Essaie un peu moins fort.
-Tu fais des making of, ou des trucs comme
ça ?
-Oui, j'en ferai un jour.
(coups de marteau)
A la fin du XIe siècle,
Putain...
A la fin du...
Putain, ça me fait chier.
A la fin du Xe siècle, les Scandinaves se
convertissent au catholicisme...
Au christianisme.
Ouais.
S'il y avait eu un troisième Empire, on parle...
Merde !
Bonjour, Cunégonde, cosplayeuse professionnelle.
J'ai soif.
J'reviens.
Allez, celle-là c'est la bonne.
Eh ouais.
(coups de marteau)
On ne peut donc pas désigner comme viking
l'ensemble de la population Scandinave, et
on leur a aussi donné des dons diff...
Des NOMS ! On leur a donné des dons...
Ambulance.
C'est bon, elle s'tire.
Ça va être chaud.
Ah merde !
Bonjour ! Pourrions-nous nous p...
Ah meeerde !
Troisième test, et après, c'est parti !
Hihihi, j'en ai maaarre...
(coups de marteau)
Astrid qui se mouche c'est fantastique.
C'est notamment le cas de l'edda de Snorri,
qui est l'une des principales sources sur
la métallogie...
La métalogie.
La métallogie, yeeeeah !
Le tramway qui passe c'est fantastique.
Eh ouais.
(coups de marteau)
Technoviking.
Ils pouvaient être équipés de haches, mais
elles étaient plutôt des armes de...Fais
gaffe, vise-moi !